In this video we're
going to try to learn
a little bit about reflection.
Or I guess you could say we are
going to reflect on reflection.
I think most of us have
a sense of what this is,
but we'll try to get a little
bit more exact about it.
So there are actually
two types of reflection,
and everything that reflects
is doing one or the other,
or something in between.
So we have two types.
Let me draw them.
So the first type, and this
is kind of what we normally
associate with reflection
is specular reflection.
And in specular
reflection, let's say
that this is the
top of a mirror.
This is the surface of a mirror.
If I have a light
ray coming in-- So
let me draw a light
ray coming in.
And just to get the
terminology right,
this light ray coming in,
this ray, is the incident ray.
And it's the incident
ray because it's
the ray as it approaches
the reflective surface.
Let me write that down.
That right there is
the incident ray.
It'll approach the surface.
And you can almost imagine
that it bounces off
at essentially the same angle,
but in the other direction.
So then it'll hit the surface,
and then it'll bounce off,
and it'll go just like that.
And then we would call
this the reflected ray,
after it is kind of
bounced off of the surface.
Reflected ray.
And you may have
already noticed this
if you've played around a lot
with mirrors you would see--
and we're going to
look at some images.
So you can think about
it a little better.
Next time you're in
front of the bathroom
mirror you can think
about this, and think
about the angle of incidence
and the angle of reflection.
But they're actually equal.
So let me define
them right here.
So if I were to just
drop a straight line
that is at a 90
degree, or that is
perpendicular to the
surface of the actual mirror
right over here, we would
define this, right here,
as the angle of incidence.
I'll just use theta.
That's just a fancy letter to
show that the angle at which
we're coming in, the
angle between this ray
and the vertical right there,
that's the angle of incidence.
And then the angle
between that vertical
and the blue ray
right there, we call
that the angle of reflection.
And it's just a property
of especially mirrors when
you're having
specular reflection.
And you can see
this for yourself
at all the regular mirrors
that you might experience
is that the angle
of incidence is
equal to the angle
of reflection.
And actually we could
see that in a couple
of images over here.
So let me show you some
images of specular reflection,
just to make it clear here.
So you have some light from
the sun hitting this mountain.
And we're going to talk
about diffuse reflection
in a little bit, and
that's what's happening.
It's being reflected diffusely.
That's why we don't see the
actual image of the sun here.
We just see the white.
But then those white light
rays, and they're actually
being scattered in every
direction, some of them
are hitting the water.
I'm going to try to match
up parts of the mountain.
So you have this
part of the mountain.
Let me do this in
a better color.
You have this part of
the mountain up here,
and the part of the
reflection right over there.
So what's happening
right here is
light is coming from that
part of the mountain,
hitting this part of the
surface of the water.
Let me see if I can
draw this better.
It's hitting this part of
the surface of the water,
and then it's getting
reflected, specular reflection,
to our eyes.
And it's actually
coming straight at us,
but I'll draw it
at a slight angle.
And then it's just coming
straight to our eyes like this.
If our eye was-- Let's
say our eye was here.
It's actually coming straight
out at us so I actually
should just draw
a vertical line,
but hopefully this
makes it clear.
And what we just said,
the angle of incidence
is equal to the
angle of reflection,
so if you were to
draw a vertical,
and it might not be that obvious
here, but this angle right
over here-- Let me draw
this a little darker color.
This angle right over
here, that's the angle--
Let me do that in a light color.
This right here is
the incident angle.
We drew a vertical.
And the angle at
which the light ray
is approaching the
surface of the water,
right before it bounces,
that's the incident angle
relative to vertical.
And then this angle
right here-- and I
know it's hard-- it doesn't
look like they're the same
but that's just because
of the perspective
that we're dealing with.
This is the angle of reflection.
And they're actually
going to be equal.
And you could also
make a similar case.
And sometimes my brain has
easier thinking about this.
If this angle is
equal to that angle--
and this is what's defined
to be the angle of incidence
and the angle of
reflection-- we also
know that this
angle, right here,
is going to be equal to
that angle right there.
And my brain sometimes
thinks that because that's
kind of the angle between the
ray and the actual surface,
but they're really
the same notions.
And obviously it's
a different angle,
but if this is equal to that
then this is equal to that
because these two are
going to add to 90,
these two are
going to add to 90.
So another way you
could view it is-- So
if we look at the
surface of the water.
Let me draw a line along
the surface of the water.
Another way to think about it
is that this angle, this angle
right over here, is going
to be the same as this angle
right over there.
And you can also see it in this
reflection right over here.
So the light from the sun is
going directly to the water
here, and then getting reflected
at that point on the surface
of the water, and then
coming over to our eyes.
And so we could either
say that this angle is
equal to this angle, so the
angle between the incident ray
and the surface of the
water is equal to the angle
of the reflected ray and
the surface of the water,
or we could draw a
perpendicular right over here--
I'm not doing that too well-- we
can draw a perpendicular right
over here to the
surface of the water,
and say that the incident
angle, the angle of incidence
right there between the
ray and that perpendicular,
is going to be the same
as the reflected angle.
And it's hard to see
there, once again,
because of the
perspective, but hopefully
that starts to make sense.
And I encourage you,
go to your bathroom
and look in the mirror, and
look at objects in the mirror,
and think about the angle
that the light from the object
must be hitting the mirror
for it to get to your eye,
and where it's actually
hitting the mirror.
It's actually a pretty
interesting thing
to do if you're looking for
things to do in the bathroom.
Now all we've talked about
is specular reflection,
but the other type of reflection
is diffuse reflection.
And this is the
type of reflection
that it may not be
as obvious to you
that it's occurring
everywhere you look.
Diffuse reflection.
And in diffuse reflection,
because the surface
isn't smooth, it's not
what we kind of associate
as a mirrored surface.
So I'll draw it,
I'll zoom in a bunch.
So in diffuse reflection,
maybe the surface looks
like that, what happens
is-- and let me be clear.
In specular reflection
any light ray
that comes in like that,
the reflection will come off
at the same-- the
angle of incidence
will always be equal to
the angle of reflection.
This is for the situation
of, say, a mirror.
It'll always be the same.
If I come in at a
steeper angle, then I'll
go out in a steeper
angle, just like that.
That's for specular reflection.
For diffuse reflection all
sorts of crazy things happen.
And that's because we don't
have this really smooth surface,
or the molecules that
make up the surface
do crazy things to light.
So if I come in in one
direction, right over here,
over at that point
the light might
reflect in that direction.
Although if I come in at
the same angle over here,
now all of a sudden the light
might go in that direction.
And then if I come in at
the same angle over here,
now all of a sudden the light
might go in that direction.
And if I come in-- and I think
you get the general idea here--
if I come in over
here, now the light
might scatter in that direction.
If I come in over here
at the same angle,
now the light might
scatter in that direction.
So the general idea is,
with diffuse reaction,
the reflected rays are going in
all sorts of crazy directions,
and they're getting
all mixed up.
So think about here, if you
had an image here of the sun,
and I'm not drawing
it in particular,
but let's say that these rays
right here are coming directly
from the sun, then
when they reflect
it'll kind of
preserve the image.
You'll have the reflected
image of the sun.
But over here, if all
of these light rays
are coming from the
sun, they're not all
going off in the same direction.
This will be a part of
the sun, part of the sun.
And it's happening at a
really, really small level.
So you're really just
capturing the light,
but you're losing all
of the information
from the actual image.
And if you're wondering where
diffuse reflection occurs just
look around your room.
Anything that's not a mirror
is reflecting diffusely.
It's diffusing the light.
Do you see that here?
The mountain right here
is diffuse reflection.
You have light
coming from the sun,
but that's being reflected in
all sorts of crazy directions.
So you don't see a reflection
of the sky over here.
The water here, that's
specular reflection
because it's so super
smooth that it preserves--
The angle of incidence is going
to be the angle of reflection.
It's always going to be
the same angle because it's
a kind of almost
perfectly smooth surface.
The trees, that's
diffuse reflection.
And I also want to be clear
on something like the trees.
So on something that's
white, and white
is the entire
spectrum of light--
and we'll do more videos
on that in the future--
it's reflecting the
entire spectrum.
It's just mixing
it all up so you
don't see an actual reflection.
But if you look
at the trees, you
have the entire spectrum
from the sun coming down
on the trees, but the trees
themselves-- and you should
watch the videos on
photosynthesis-- they're
absorbing every other frequency
of light except for the greens
you see.
So they are just reflecting
the green back to us.
And they're doing it in
a way they're diffusely
reflecting it.
So we actually don't
see an actual reflection
in those trees.
And I'll just finish up
with one kind of neat thing
because it's kind of
like playing billiards
here, because you can actually
have a double reflection.
That's why I even had
this image over here.
The sun is being reflected
on the water here,
and then you have a reflection.
This is a direct
reflection of the sun,
but this is a reflection
of the sun reflected
on the water right over here.
So what you have over
here is the light
from the sun coming
to this reflection,
reflecting at that
point on the water,
then going to this
point on the paddle,
and then coming to our eye.
But once again the angle of
incidence in every situation
here is going to be equal
to the angle of reflection.
Although the paddle looks like
it's a little bit distorted
here, so it's not a
completely smooth surface,
so it makes the math
a little harder.
But when you start
thinking about this
it becomes pretty
interesting just
to look at almost any
reflective surfaces
and to think about
the actual angles.